resuming the meeting after a quick 10
minute break
um right we've done apologies for
absence so I'll move on to a gender item
three which is the minutes it's recorded
at the minutes of the meeting held on
the 26th of January 2023 found on pages
5 to 22 and the
um the continuation of the meeting on
the 9th of February
2022 on pages 23 26 to 23-66 are
approved as a true and accurate record I
so move do I have a seconder for that
motion thank you counselor and
um okay moving one Kevin yep sorry
um yeah I know you were seconded uh just
a query actually might have been
answered by what I see on the screen up
there but regarding the meeting of the
9th of February where it was a
continuation and it's on page 29 and
under 14 it was an urgent business
private confidential it does say in
response to a point of order and
questions raise the senior specialist
legal provided the committee with the
now at that meeting there was only one
director present and one other officer
um so can I ask coming soon now and the
Holmes on there was Emma Holmes
presenter I couldn't recall that so I
just asked that the clarification it may
have been that Emma was present like she
is tonight but I just couldn't remember
that but how can we call Mr Holmes been
there and I can remember Sue green
um there was no one no other officer
present but it does say there was a
response from the senior specialist
legal so I just asked was that done via
on on screen because I noticed Emma's
there tonight I couldn't recall it
um
know if um Miss Holmes was present
okay thank you
I couldn't check on the recording
because obviously private confidential
what I could only see is the first part
of the meeting
foreign
apologies
okay no problem um thank you councilor
channel for pointing that one out very
well spotted
okay moving on
moving on to agenda item four which is
disclosure of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other registerable
interests and non-restrial interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph nine
and appendix B of the code of conduct
for members members are reminded that
they are also required to disclose any
such interests as soon as they become
aware should the knees arise throughout
the meeting so do we have any
disclosures for interest
nope okay
public participation to receive the
views of members of the public of which
prior notification in writing has been
received no later than noon on the
Tuesday prior to the day of the meeting
um do we have any public speakers Tara
Monday
[Music]
Microsoft every meeting and and Miss
home towards the president in that
meeting oh she was present okay
um thank you Miss bird
hey
no no problem at all well well done for
uh a party okay right agenda item six
which is the climate action plan for 23
24 and Mr Holmes is going to present
this item thank you chairman good
evening members I welcome the
opportunity to present to you this
excellent piece of work this evening the
climate action plan was developed over a
four-month period in collaboration with
officers across all services and
functions to comprise a set of smart
actions that specific measurable agreed
relevant and time-bound the actions are
linked directly to the five approved
core pledges that are set out in the
climate action strategy and as a
reminder they are kick the car habit
create less waste show nature We Care be
an authority that leads by example and
have a strong policy commitment to
climate action
each action has been given a short
medium or long term for higher time
frame and a desired output we would
propose to track progress quarterly
through the council's performance
governance and Order committee the
actions has also been linked to
co-benefits that link to the Community
Place economic growth and such as
producing improving health and
increasing jobs and increasing Community
engagement
actions will be either undertaken by the
council or in collaboration with
external partners and often funding will
be sought or hopefully allocated in some
cases a list of external Partners is set
out on page six of the action plan
the initial climate action plan sets out
our community engagement actions for
2023-2024. throughout this time we will
continue to engage and support the
community with their activities we
already have approved budget for this in
the 23-24 year
the climate action plan supports our new
corporate plan priority for agreeing a
future
having this climate action plan will
enable the council to actively deliver
against the corporate plan our climate
action strategy and therefore
demonstrates the strategy through to
delivery this update to members is a
positive step in identifying ways to
reduce carbon emissions and increase
climate resilience across the district
the recommendation is that members note
The Climb action plan and approve that
the plan will be monitored and reports
through the performance governance and
audit committee itself
unfortunately our climate officer is
unwell with Kobe this evening but your
Gina button is kindly made yourself
available this evening to assist with
any questions members might have thank
you chairman okay thank you members
[Music]
okay councilor login
thank you chair
um I agree with Mr Holmes um on this
occasion it's a very good piece of work
there's a couple of questions I think
about three that I'd um like to consider
um first one is um section 3.9 and page
68 yes we've talked about the targets
and I've looked at the targets and the
designated outputs but I've also I have
a concern about the long-term targets
now I know that we're going to be
reviewing these but there's no specific
time-bound unit of measurement that says
we we aim to achieve our aspirations to
achieve by this state this action we
just have a long-term medium term with a
year on it
so I'd personally like to see a little
bit more detail with
um it will be done by x amount and then
what the units of measurement are
against about raising that Target so the
detail about what the action plan
actually is about the target
um I find in section four
um 4.2 it we talk about you know we're
taking a climate emergency series we've
got to embed that in everything we do
and we went down the problem the other
day and there was a diesel ice cream van
pumping away out there and that was
raised in the past and concerned by
members so if we're going to do this we
need to do this properly so we need to
use it as part of every part of our
decision making process and I understand
why that unit's there but
I hope you understand the intent of
which I'm making that statement
um
interested in really how much the plan
is going to cost us I know we've got
allocated funds but I'd like to actually
know what what the actual Financial
spend is
um and 3.5 on page 67 talks of external
funding opportunities can that be
explained in more details what that they
actually are because we've got the
partners but where's this funding coming
from and I know some of its aspirations
to get money in from other other areas
and other funds and we're we're good at
that but I'd like to know a bit more
about that
and uh second from last point is how
does the climate action strategy work
alongside planning applications when we
know that it's one of the areas of a
great concern when cycle paths Bridal
ways and bus transportation is often
sadly lacking and the Synergy that's
needed to have a holistic transport
action plan is a challenge for us all
um so really it's it's a great piece of
work I absolutely um concur with that
but they're the areas that I'd like to
have a little bit more detail on if if
that's possible please thank you okay I
think Miss button will be able to help
with that one this button yeah I'll try
and run through that list and get um
members and chair
um so going back to
um
so our planet action strategy sets out
the period of the strategy we trans up
until 2030
um so I think Claire our client officer
is has set out the definition of short
medium and long term and then against
each of the actions she has set out
whether it is a short meeting or
long-term achievable action reminding
members that is planned just for the
period of the next 12 months so it's not
a full eight year plan it is an annual
action plan as committed and approved by
the climate action strategy so it is
delivering again to the commitment to
set out what we're going to achieve
um in the next 12 months but what Claire
has kindly done is also included that
longer term thinking for medium term
long term it's a long term moving in
their lives 2017
um and yeah you know we have to start
looking at what those number term things
are and if they are achievable but
um most climate action plans
anywhere between 200 and 300 actions in
them
find the action is huge and it does
cover everything that we do with this
counselor lag and as rightly said in
terms of invading it in everything we do
that's something we have done we've
provided staff and training members with
carbon electric literacy training and we
will be continuing to do that we ask for
everybody we financially
incorporates a green option so that even
if it's incredibly expensive it's still
set out as an option with the benefits
so that members have the option to make
that decision if sustainability is I
think the priority and if it's simply
enough then obviously at least at least
it's been included as an option
but you're right Council lag and we we
are trying very much to work across the
whole of the council with staff to
ensure that there is that climate action
thinking to the point that every member
of Staff where they've got their smart
personal smart objectives they've been
asked to have a climate action objective
so that they are bringing it into the
work that they're doing and that will
only improve as we do more and more of
this over the next few years
in terms of budget that was approved
last year so there was a growth bid in
last year's budget that was approved and
what that did was approve uh budget for
the resource which is the climate action
officer and an engagement budget over a
three-year period
um and so for next year that was only 24
000. off my head twenty four thousand
eight hundred
um for the next 12 months so obviously
not a huge amount but it don't enable us
to work with our community groups and
our partners to be able to engage and
promote the work that we're doing does
it enable us to deliver major
infrastructure programs major projects
no it doesn't because that has to be
done through the engagement with our
partners as set out on page six and we'd
have to work with them to make sure that
this District receives either an
allocation of funding or is included in
the rollout of any programs that Essex
County Council and other partners
deliver
so that's what this plan is trying to
set out to do it's stating what those
activities are and who we're working
with to make sure that this district is
receiving some engagement and or
ultimately see
um some delivery from that
um what was your questions okay
[Music]
yeah I think um
yeah budget I've got that yeah I just a
quick come up and I thank you it's
really refreshing to have somebody come
back and give you the detail
um to the question
um so thank you Miss button for that
um I do have still have a concern about
the targets and the the makeup of those
and the structure of that
um but I think that gives me a bit more
reassurance and and comfort uh within
what was being presented so I thank you
Miss button
councilor Morgan and then councilor
Channel
uh yeah think about him chairman having
recently become a cyclist I've got a
personal interest in this particular
question I'm just looking at the kick
the hawk sorry kick of the car habit
part and whilst I see cycling is
actually mentioned I don't see any
mention of cycle Lanes is there any plan
to include these in the in the highways
or roads or anywhere with the high-risk
authority to actually include these tour
in the in the districts of road road
work
and we do that already within our face
work so I'll play stress she didn't need
works very closely
um with our national cycle forecast to
make sure that there is that
connectivity and that has been completed
in the work that we're doing with Essex
County Council under developing our
sustainable transport strategic
transport strategy which is working
right now with Essex County Council and
so a key part of that to making sure
that cycle Lane infrastructure is in
place and that our district is connected
through through those cycle Lanes so
when that when that strategic transport
strategy is ready to present and share
with you will be able to present exactly
what that looks like
okay thank you that's that's helpful but
are they actually going to be
specifically marked on the roadway at
all
are they going to be marked on the road
cycle routes
[Music]
itself so it'll be screen bursting basis
in terms of the markings
um
so
um if I had a officer Jackie Longman
with me right now she's going to take
that detail but we can certainly come
back to you on that uh Council Norman if
that helps but
um yeah absolutely please be assured
that where there is the opportunity to
provide a proper cycle Lane markings we
are asking for that thank you okay thank
you and councilor Channel
uh thank you madam chairman uh first of
all I'd just like to say I think this is
button's been involved in this from the
very beginning the strategy and
obviously the action plan so I think
it's an admiral piece of work and I'm
very pleased we've now got the climate
action officer on board because
certainly in the short time she has been
here
um there has been some really good work
done in terms of how locally we're
working with parishes and certainly I'm
aware of the haybridge group there's
tollsbury as well and we've got the
Dengue Dengue group as well which is
doing some good work getting our
residents involved what I'd like to ask
is I mean we've been for a while now
without our coast and Countryside
officer and I see there's a fair number
of elements within here that falls to
the responsibility and I believe we've
now got a coast and Countryside officer
on board
um I'm particularly interested in the
green infrastructure strategy because
that went back to 2019 it appears to be
a high priority area um when we're
talking about that I think I'll go with
councilor lag and I'd like to know in
terms of what that does mean and I'm
also very interested and was with the
previous coast and Countryside officer
regarding to participating in the Essex
Forest initiative and the tree planting
and I just wonder how that will be
reported to members because I'd be quite
interested to see the outcomes as it
were I think sometimes we can have
outputs and this isn't a criticism
because I think this is an excellent
document but obviously I'm very keen in
seeing outputs
outcomes rather not outputs outcomes so
I wonder if I could just have assurances
that a lot of this work which the new
office has come on board for will be of
high priority areas thank you
uh thank you Mr Holmes Jim yes to just
to reassure members the officer started
this week I'm very experienced officer
and comfortable background with the
environment agency about this uh fully
skilled with a number of attributes will
help us complete this work so absolutely
we'll contribute to this plan um say
first week in and that will be part of
his um his own smart objectives to
actually deliver against this plan so we
can give you that assurance
okay councilor Swain and then councilor
Shaughnessy yes thank you um
three things and I was at the
um
this is climate conference here a couple
of days ago which was concerned with
retrofitting
um and uh obviously we're not directly
involved much in that but it does mean
that we need to be sure that um what
housing associations are doing
um who do have access to their special
funds and to be sure they're doing what
they can do
um to retrofit um housing in in their
housing associations
um uh the other aspect on housing is
whether we can whether we will be able
to insist in um with new developments
through in the through the long through
the local development plan on all new
housing being of the top energy rating
levels a on b or whatever
um
lastly if I refer back to um
uh councilor Morgan's Point I think was
on cycle Advance
um it's quite clear that a lot of roads
in um
particularly in Malden I won't speak for
Burnham but in Malden
um there just isn't the scope to
delineate separate
um uh Lanes except on the some of the
outer roads perhaps
um but this is one of the reasons or the
alternative approach which I've been
advocating is to have a 20 mile an hour
zone for the center of the Town
um which the idea of which is to
encourage a different culture
amongst drivers and and to make it more
safer for cyclists as well as
pedestrians of course and that may be
more practical given the very narrow
um restrictive nature of Our Town Center
roads here
and then cancel it
opened a brainstorm now still sorry
okay cancel cancel sorry
thank you
can I speak gents please thank you thank
you
thank you chair
um
I too would like to um yes congratulate
Georgina and the team behind this of
course because a lot of work has gone
into it
but I have to say there is one glaring
omission
and that is diet
now we should all know that meat is what
meat eating is one of the huge polluters
across the world and it is very rarely
mentioned because it's not popular
but that is a fact and I think it should
come into all of these strategies you
know you're not going to change people's
eating habits overnight
but if we ignore it completely then
they're not even going to change a
little
you know there is far too much meat
eating in this country in other
countries around the world some
countries don't even have the luxury of
it and they're probably healthier than
us as well in some cases
but it but it is a fact and and I would
like it
um to be introduced into
um into these um strategies and I would
like some comments on that please thank
you
button
so in terms of Rich fitting yeah we
don't have our own stock however
um I make sure I meet with our grand
housing Partners to make sure they have
a
decarbonisation plan so that they are
improving the fabric of their housing
stock
um in every number of issues in terms of
making housing sound but it's also
making sure it's sustainable for the
future and how housing providers are
doing that if I applying to the
decarbonization fund and once they are
successful with that I'm also using
their own uh their own investment and
they are then either offsetting or they
are simply investing in in retrofitting
and we do have examples of that in the
district
um saying through with with energy
sprawl and other initiative so it's
something we want to continue working
with and we are expecting our housing
providers to have a clear plan of how
they're going to support I think we're
also working with other purposes County
Council and businesses that are
providing skills and training so that
jobs are created to be able to
um you know ensure that that retrogrity
can take place and it can download
through our and our local economy
benefits from that and the second point
was existing new developments um you
know adhere to these sorts of
expectations absolutely the policy and
legislation will do that and do that
through the future home standards of
which we will have to maintain and
ensure our policies are up to up to date
and shows that we do have a strong
policy commitment to climate action and
that's something that our client action
officer and our plan quality team are
uh to Artistic work with our
understandment management team in
planning to make sure that we are
consciously mindful of that and bringing
that into the work that we're doing and
then I think it'll be 20 miles it's been
so into absolutely and I think that also
goes out in hand with the air quality
management that we're we're working on
in that
transport
ation Council so again we will be kind
of bringing back you know to end this
representation at some point later this
year
and then just go back to councilman
Shaughnessy uh yeah I suppose um the
difficulty that we have is um veganism
and promoting it is a sensitive matter
but what we have already done in terms
of local economies we have welcomed uh
vegan markets to the district
um and we have through our community
work through our health and well-being
one walking District partnership made
sure that we are making sure that
climate actually feeds into the work of
the community and strategies being so
that there are the unconsciousness
initiatives which is set out on the
climate action plan but we're providing
things senior practice growing
vegetables within your own garden
providing training for that what we're
not necessarily doing is leading on
campaigns that talks about meat eating
being a bad thing because that's not
necessarily for us to lead on that
agenda but we are here to educate them
all in terms of options that people can
have for their health and their
well-being and that we're trying to give
them a choice and the skills to be able
to take part in things to actually
entity kitchens growing your own and
it's making sure that links through to
so much more better health outcomes so I
don't think it's it's not that it's um
it's not the work isn't taking place I
think we are very much doing all the bad
but probably more through our health and
well-being work that we that we're
focused on through other strategies and
well-being alliances
come back
yes thank you chair thanks very much
um I think we can do more I wasn't
suggesting going straight to veganism
either I mean you know there is a
halfway point but she's vegetarianism
you know which includes cheese and eggs
and things
um so um so yeah I'm not I'm not
thrilled with the response to be
perfectly honest with you
um but you know I'll have to leave it
there I shall run my personal campaign
thank you councilor siddle
thank you madam chairman uh one of the
things they that um would be nice for us
to see I don't and I don't know whether
we have signed up this to this at all uh
but one of the things that the parishes
have been doing and yeah we've done it
at our parish and that is to pass a
motion that the parish supports 20 is
plenty across Essex so there's a 20-20
scheme for all residential areas
is that something that the council
should sign up to as well to support
that campaign yeah and be part of that
campaign in terms of introducing 20 is
plenty across all residential areas in
the district that's my first point
I think that's something okay
yeah so yeah because I think that's one
of the crucial ways that we're lobbying
Essex County council at the moment is by
signing up to that scheme
um I I think the report is fantastic I
think the aims are fantastic my concern
is
we're trying to do too much with not
enough resource
yeah so that that's that's the debate
and it's I know it's in one of the key
risks is the lack of resources to
deliver the plan so I think what we've
got to try and do is is try and be
clever about it and try and prioritize
where our focus should be so last week
for example and Essex is the one that's
got the money for all this and to a
certain extent has got uh investment to
do things last week I went round uh the
little Tottenham Parish with an officer
from Essex County Council and we have
planned five acres of new trees in this
autotum and those trees are coming free
part of his model District Council and
so I need to speak to Richard about that
but it is about you know those are the
sort of things we've got to encourage
parishes to do that's what we've got to
Essex to do I said to him yeah out of
the whole of Essex how many parishes
have engaged with you it was 10.
uh the whole of Essex
yeah so we need to in terms of us is to
really get yeah Claire I think to to try
and get behind that and get other
parishes in the modern District to get
involved in all these free trees we've
got until 2025 to access these free
trees
um that's the sort of thing again that
that you know we do we're now looking at
restoration of a pond so it's all those
things that we can really make a
difference and accessing those things
from Essex County Council
um and you're right those bodies are
really really important because there is
only so much that modern District
Council can do but I think it's great we
but we need to focus we need to
prioritize it we need to make sure that
we are badgering those people to deliver
from Olden
um councilor Thompson
thank you
chairman um
yeah congratulations Georgina and the
whole team excellent piece of work
everyone else has always said it but
please believe I I support them in all
of that
um Mrs button has already touched on the
producing local food and I think that's
that is very important because
I have a feeling although I have no
figures that are locally raised cow or
sheep probably does less damage to the
environment than slipping coconuts and
almonds from the other side of the world
where growing them uses fantastic
amounts of water as well
um the other thing the issue with dairy
and I understand that and also by the
way I I am a vegetarian who doesn't farm
so I have no accidents
um the dairy industry relies very
heavily on the meat industry because
cows have babies and somebody has to do
something with the babies because
roughly half of those are male and
without a beef industry
there really is no dairy industry
so that's that's going to be fun to look
at one of these days
thank you
okay counseling well this is a fun time
you can come back because I want to keep
this meeting on track so Council again
then Council Channel then councilor
fluka yeah I'll just normally with
cancer Shawnee so I normally agree with
nearly everything as you say but I would
absolutely hate for us to put that type
of view into this type of document I
think the awareness and the the
awareness and the education my wife's
pescetarian we don't eat hardly any meat
at all now because of the things where
we have we don't have intensive farming
yeah but that's a personal choice flow
what we've turned in here is we're
forcing people to be something that they
have a choice to be that's not art roll
for that our role is to educate and give
people the option if they want to do it
shouldn't fit in this plan
okay thank you and councilor Channel
thank you madam chairman
um just a question really and I'm sure
Georgina and Claire are aware of this
um are we aware that well I'm gonna
answer questions now of having said
she's probably aware of it the Net Zero
Innovation program that the LGA are
involved in because today I actually
went to the um there was sustainability
regarding Council Services webinar and
it was from The Innovation Hub and that
was very very interesting hearing other
councils and how they're doing this and
about the sustainability and about zero
carbon and what actually Authority
should be doing across all our services
actually not just leaving it and think
just sort of a couple of elements or so
there's a way we have integration across
this across the whole of the council so
Georgina's not being so she she is aware
so that so that's fine but it was very
very um enlightening I have to say thank
you okay thank you councilor fluka
so I did miss
a couple of things um yeah I appreciate
that we agreed to budget for this some
time ago don't have a problem with that
but when we did we didn't know what the
outcome was going to be how bad it was
going to be for for this financial year
and we certainly didn't know how bad it
was for the next financial year so I
think going forward
um I think that when we are dealing with
non-statutry
um work lines work streams
um I think we should have a little bit
more in impact on resources Financial so
members can actually see what we're
investing in non-statitary
um the delivery of non-statitude
projects I mean overarchingly I don't
have a problem with this I mean I've
I've totally accept uh councilor
shawness's view
um but then if we go down that line and
we accept what this report says which
basically said we should have lots of
solar Farms everywhere then we won't be
growing any crops or eating any meat so
I'm not sure where that takes us to but
Jim I've got a few points to to raise so
I'll be as brief as I can
um on the introduction chairman for some
bizarre reason I've lost my numbers page
numbers but on the on the introduction
it says avoid carbon intensive
activities
um I mean the point I'd like to raise
there is is that we're just about to
spend a hundred thousand pounds cutting
down trees uh in in principally the
Promenade Park
um I wonder whether or not we're
realigning our procurement now to ensure
that
um contractors use biofuels or even
hydrogen units and I know that there are
some tree surgeons in the district that
actually do operate using such equipment
so I think it's really important that we
look at who uh how our contractors that
we're procured with are actually going
to operate within this plan
um
sorry I've got no page numbers on this
for some bizarre reason so I'm now on
the one which oh big pays 75.
um look Market Hill this has been
dragging on forever and a day
um you know we've been talking about
this for a long long time so I think we
need to either do something about Market
Hill and the air quality
um we were hoping to get receptors at
latchingdon because there's the National
Health Service have identified a problem
in legenda now
um so it'd be nice to to do that as well
um so moving on to my next point
which is on page 77
um I mean this is hugely ambiguous this
and and you know it we've got it says
that the council will Lobby Essex County
Council for funding for walking and
cycling projects via mtfts and
designated funds from the a12 widening
so what we're going to do is we're going
to we're going to sort of widen the a12
bring lots more cars on into it because
that's why we widen it so the car's
going and then we're going to take money
out of that and put it into this I mean
one wonders whether or not we should be
telling people not to drive their cars
on the a12 and abide by this policy
which by the way I don't think you can
implement it I think policy on vehicles
should be to encourage people to have
electric cars determine like yourself
and I and and have
um have dual fuel um because that's
clearly the game The Way Forward
so I thought that was a little bit
ironic
um and there's something else in here
and I I mean I'll happily give way to
the uh the section 151 officer but on
page 78
um it talks about uh deterring car use
in modern Town Center
well if we were to deter car use in
modern Town Council Morton Town Center
then the mtfs will fall on its head
because it's dependent on car park
income so are we saying that we're going
to deter it and that's going to affect
the MTF I I don't know
um it doesn't seem to me very joined up
to me and I can see Miss button nodding
so I'm not expecting to come back on all
of these I just hoping you'll take them
on on board but there just seems to be a
complex there between the medium-term
financial strategy the central area
master plan and um and the cap so
um I shall go on
um
and then on page
seven I think it's page A2 79 or 80 and
this is the one improving waste life
cycle so that we are managing most more
staining now look
we're talking here about having flats or
as we call them these days Apartments
um
but this Council in the last three
months has approved planning
applications where where you've got
co-mingled collections for apartment
blocks so this really makes no sense
either you know we stop this or we don't
but I don't we can't say we're going to
encourage them to do this because the
last developers that came into this
chamber
um for one of the hay Bridge development
sites I asked them you know I checked
tonight and I listened to the tape and I
said to them are you going to provide
proper recycling areas so that the
people that live in these apartments can
recycle that can sort their own wastes
like most of us do and the answer was no
they're going to just have one big bin
store for 10 Apartments everything goes
in co-mingle so we certainly need to do
some work around that
so I'm going to switch I've just found
an awful lot more
um so the next next one is protect an
enhanced biodiversity in the council to
State well that's interesting because I
was in the Promenade Park last week and
they were appear to be spraying
everything we'd Round Up
um so chemical weed killers and
fertilizers
I mean this really needs to be that it
really needs to be
um
there needs to be a deep dive in some to
some of these statements in relation to
what our existing
um practices are and and on page 81 now
I've got a question this button I'm
dying to find out and you can wait to
learn more a water cycle study completed
is because
um I'm not sure what that is but I was
at uh Hollywood outfall the other day
and and I was watching South minister of
sewage Farm pumping untreated sewage
into the Crouch I'm not sure if that's
what that's to do with but I would like
to know what a water cycle study is
um
hang on I'm going
so then I go on to link exercise to
waste I mean this is quite a bizarre one
um you know we're around Ashland danger
in South Minster we do sort of six liter
picks a year yeah
um I don't think we're any of us are
sort of uh
exposed to jogging while we're doing it
but you know this this what it says here
they have to jog now when you do your it
says it's support promote existing new
litter picking activities across the
district
um so that's basically saying it's okay
to litter
the way I read that what this should say
is this this should run in line with a
policy that we should always without
fail prosecute people that do drop
litter and fly tip I mean I find that
quite strange that one
and uh and then the um the welcoming
solar farm developments
well we've heard comments tonight about
not eating meat we've all got to eat we
know that the price of grain has gone
through the roof and of course every
time you have a solar farm development
regardless of what the developer says at
the time if you visit one afterwards you
will just see that underneath all of the
panels it's basically a desert and I
think Rose and uh
the biodiversity is not brilliant it's
it's a fact so
um I'm surprised that that one
is in there
and then I think on page 82
um
includes farms located in the Upper
Black Water Area More Than This is
supports sustainable farming
I mean unless you throw money at the
farmers they will not support
sustainable farming it's up to the
businesses it's up to the farmers
whether they'd buy into this and I don't
think many will knowing how they've lost
their EU grants
and I've already spoken about the the
tree contract and it it goes into
um on page 83 it does actually cover
this off about making sure that whoever
we procure with yeah and that the
companies that they demonstrate
sustainability and support the council's
Net Zero carbon Ambitions so when I
drill into the letting of the drill a
drill lesson until letting you know the
tree contract which I understand Essex
County Council or letting
um then I will expect to see that one of
the criterias is that that we make sure
that they are going to support this
policy because I I my well I believe
that the companies that do use these
type of question equipment
um failed to get on the procurement list
at the council
and hopefully chill no sorry chairman
well I've spoken to food production so I
won't dwell on that any longer on page
84.
and a question
um on page 85 it says Human Resources
code of conduct
being reviewed to consider various
matters including impacts on environment
so I'm not quite sure
what that means
um Miss button
and and that is my lock chair
he counts left Luca so I'm quite happy
for Miss button just to have a listen to
the tape afterwards and respond back to
us all on the point side of raised
um but I do think you know there's some
stuff in there that does tend to
conflict with other policies
particularly the medium term Financial
strategy which concerns me enormously
yeah thank you as chair I've got a few
comments that I'd like to make anyway
and um you know when we talk about
pledge one which is kick the car I'm a
bit disappointed that we're not being
um more proactive
um on the
um the the solar panels and charges for
cars I'd like to say that being
selective or encouraging people to get
their own car charges to enable electric
car use so I've said we both use cars
that's one thing I'd like to see um
Coming forwards and
um the car parking that was brought up
not so which councilor brought that up
that was a very good point because it is
one of our very good income streams
um and I'd like to see rather than
trying to ban cars I'd like to see a way
of encouraging
um electric or hydrogen or other cars
and vehicles to come in and use our
lovely studies because we need the
tourism and we need the income from car
park so for me that's vastly important
so we've got to be careful we don't cut
our nose off to spite our face and it's
all about the emissions um so I think
that's something I'd like to see built
in and again I'm a bit disappointed that
that's not in there
um on pledge zero two which is to create
less waste in actual fact
um I sit on the waste committee and
um we are the pretty much I think we are
the best Authority in Essex for waste
collection and that's all down to Carol
love and I think we it was funny because
the Essex County Council was saying that
the authorities are trying to get the
waste collections we've already got and
I stood up and I said well thanks to
Carol love I said we've already got all
these systems so we can't listen our
Laurels but again I think it was
councilor fluke said we need to
prosecute when people drop litter when
they flight it we need to jump straight
on it so that's something I'd like to
see strengthened in the policy
um on the sustainable farming um I will
say that we are farmers and we have in
the past um had cattle and but I would
say most farmers are environmentally
friendly
um we've actually got one of the very
best areas for bring geese and we don't
have to keep the grass but we do
um so the government's very very pleased
with that
um and I think most farmers are the same
and also as sustainable farming um when
chemicals were touched on this is really
very highly regulated
um by defra
and I mean I have a qualified
qualification for um the application of
Springs including water-based and they
are working very closely on what
chemicals you can use how you can use
them and for instance slug pellets which
um contained
metaldehyde are banned in the UK I think
they're still usable in parts of Europe
but we've actually banned them here so I
think defra is the one to be in charge
of chemicals
um you know so I think that's a bit
beyond um molden but I think you know I
I do I do promote it and I think we
should rather than trying to kick the
car completely we we need to promote
electric cars and other cars that really
are no image emissions and we need to
all right we can change policy but for
me we need to encourage members of the
public to to put car charges in you know
we can be far more proactive and not be
held back by um you know the plans and
one thing another so I think I just
thought some of the other members of
certain counts Channel said I would like
to see this outcome based and and
focused on what the what outcomes we
want to get and local molden outcomes
not necessarily Essex wide you know me
personally I'm interested in our
district we've got a beautiful District
let's keep it that way and let's improve
it where we can but um there weren't any
questions there but I just wanted to um
say um how important it is to me right
okay members
um let's move on to agenda item seven
which is delivery oh sorry the
recommendation there hold on one second
I'll just get to it I've gone to my
little bit here we go back a page write
them the recommendations oh if I can get
on the right page are that the members
know the council's annual climate change
action plan for 23 24 attached to
appendix one and approve that it will be
monitored quarterly via quarterly
performance reports for the pgae
committee
um but I would also like to add that
into recommendation that the
um thoughts and responses of the
strategy resources committee are built
into that report as well because I think
everybody's made valuable
um uh points that I'd like to see
include and I think it's important those
points are included would that be
possible to add that in please Tara
Miss bird
of your own motion well my own motion is
that we had these in members so do I
have a second there for my motion thank
you councilor fluka okay all those um in
favor will agreed
thank you everybody okay right moving on
to finally to agenda item seven which is
delivering the corporate plan for 23.27
priority helping the economy to thrive
on pages 89 to 92 and we have Mr element
to present
thank you Chad uh good evening members
uh further to the recent approval of our
corporate priorities I'm pleased to
share with you some of the current and
future headline work streams to deliver
on helping our economy thrive
members of course recognize it continues
to be one of the most challenging and
turbulent times for local business this
is therefore a very important but broad
area of work which the whole Council
must commit to achieving
accordingly uh invites have been uh
these initiatives have been developed
with input from across the council and
with partners and we've proposed to
offer further member briefings to
provide transparency confidence as well
as additional time for member input and
hopefully all members have received
these provisional invites and subject to
approval I'll send a reminder tomorrow
and the recordings of those sessions of
course will be shared
uh we wanted to highlight uh the launch
of the locate Malden District our first
investment and business facing microsite
the formation of the modern District
tourism group known as the t23
the development of the supporting local
business program which has evolved from
the closure of our sense of place
business Network approach a point on
that is to note that the district brand
also known as sense of place and times
um is ongoing and that's unaffected by
the closure of the business Network
approach
and two projects that form part of our
shared Prosperity funded program that is
the investigation of options to
revitalize modern market and and Our
intention to work with the rural
community council of Essex to seek
magnox funding to support and enhance
the delivery of the council's rural
England Prosperity fund allocation
and so there's quite a lot in one report
so I hope it demonstrates some of the
volume and value being delivered in
Pursuit and support of our local
businesses and economy thank you
okay before before we go anywhere else
members
uh councilor swing
um I note there this uh Dimension about
a key thing being doing something about
modern Market
um I really can't see any future for the
existing outdoor Market that we have
here
um but what would be I think attractive
is
um an indoor market somewhere or and
Facilities that could be premises that
would not only allow for an indoor
market or markets but also it provide
space for other community related
activities
um that seems to be much more attractive
as as a central point
um
in line with the the idea that um High
streets now should have much more of a
Community Focus
as well as
providing scope for things like pop-up
shops which is the way I see the
Market's going
in the future
uh thank you uh councilor Swain uh Mr
Ellen yeah uh yeah very happy to come
back on that one and I'm inclined to
agree I think in all markets is a really
interesting
um opportunity unfortunately as you
understand they have significant Capital
uh or at least Revenue costs um to run
that to have the space to do that
um that's not that's not within the
budgets allocation that we're working
with at the moment however I think we I
would want us to be very positive about
any third party wanting to uh take some
space to do such a thing
um on the approach to the market in its
current location at least that's the one
considered most viable by the
consultants and the report that was
undertaken last year
um we are ex we are um exploring options
for us we're not committing any funds at
this stage
um we do have opportunity to use grant
funding for it but it would be subject
to an expression of Interest or a soft
Market
offer coming forward that we could then
run a competitive process and to support
them
uh
I might come back I thought we'd
allocated
um 25
000 to research into the feasibility of
the market which I had a bit of a query
about at the strategy and resources the
gender meeting and not quite
um we have put a 25 000 pound allocation
into our investment plan for the shared
Prosperity fund but we are running a
soft Market engagement exercise
essentially an expression of Interest
exercise where we will look for people
who want to do a market that could bring
forward a business case to us that we
could support with that those funds
if that isn't available if such an offer
if such an opportunity an expression
doesn't come forward we would not invest
any further money into any feasibility
study or anything further like that yeah
what I would suggest in a chair is that
before any money is spent it comes back
to the strategy and resources committee
because any company that wants to run
the market should be able to run their
own feasibility studies and it shouldn't
be down for the taxpayers of the Malden
District to pay for companies
feasibility studies for them to make
profits that's something I'd like um
notice please um can I have a quick come
back on that and just to point out of
course that running any extensive
outdoor markets in Black Lane is
possibly has an opportunity cost in
terms of lost parking Revenue
yeah yeah okay um right I've got
um I've got councilor Lagan and then
councilor Morgan then cancel the channel
and council is the councilor login
please thank you very much chair um I'll
stand here
um
we used to have a market didn't we you
know those of us who are always been
great and very old and very great and we
don't have one now we only have Joe up
the top
um Vlog with his watches and putting
batteries in unfortunately and so if the
Consultants are looking at putting
another marketing Back Lane then they're
the wrong Consultants sort of hired
yeah because it has it's failed for
years we're in his story if you look at
some of our text we're a historic Market
town without Market we need to bring a
market and if you look at the models
that other areas have like your
chelmsfords where it's in an area where
you have footfall and I've always
maintained we could have a very nice
periodic marker outside All Saints
Church that can run down because the
Pavements that are wide out there by the
the horse trough but that's a personal
personal view so I think we we do need a
market
um I'm not adverse to an indoor market
because I think they definitely have
Merit but as you say the capital cost
the buildings the running that they're
all a challenging issue for us
um but I really feel it should be if
you're going to have that if you're
going to capture what we had in the past
and what we really need we don't want to
be all things to all people we just need
a small
really powerful quality offering that
people can come in that will draw people
into town to park in the car park to be
able to migrate into the High Street to
be able to do their shops and support
the businesses that are there so again
I'm I'm flabbergasted Mr Allen that
they've come in and said we should stick
it in Far Lane you know thank you
okay
uh yeah I'm also old enough to remember
the old Market in I believe the car park
is still known as the former Market side
so I I'm aware of where that used to
operate the the Consultants have
identified that is is uh a viable site
and that was their recommendation I
would point out I suppose that the
former Market site was actually further
removed from the current market sites is
from The High Street so it was even more
away from The High Street Frontage not
by much I accept
um the just to be clear on this we will
be making no expenditure Grant funded or
any otherwise unless we find a viable uh
business case come forward from
potential operators
foreign
if they're good operators they'll be
able to do a feasibility study and we
shouldn't need to um okay um councilor
Morgan
oh yeah thank you chair um it's
frequently turning on Netflix I see sort
of some interesting and well-known
landmark in the background
um is does this plan include the
promotion of the district for film and
television Production Services
uh yes indeed it does we actively
promote the area for uh film
presentation and we're working with the
new Essex County council's Film office
to do that we have a specific web page
about filming in the district on our
visit modern District uh website
um I'm sure there was another point but
I think I think I've covered it if
that's okay
okay uh thank you uh councilor Channel
then councilor Fluker Club thank you
madam chairman
um obviously
um I'm sure all members like myself
appreciate the value of Tourism to our
district and how important that is and
obviously I'm pleased to see now we've
got this t23 group set up I think there
was a precursor to that t22 and
obviously what's an important
fundamental thing to me is this
framework the tourism framework which is
going to align with our events and
concessions
um is the intention that we'll have an
all member briefing on on this in due
course I'm obviously aware of a draft of
something so I think it is something
that all members of this Authority might
actually find interesting and would be
useful to you know as long as presented
in the correct context but can I just
have assurances that in due course that
will come forward thank you
uh thank you leader and um yeah that is
book for Wednesday next week and the
invites have been sent hopefully to all
members I'll send a reminder
um tomorrow to make sure everyone's got
a
yeah okay oh is it the three the three
yes for clarity there are three in the
same series one is on in with investment
and supporting local business the second
is on uh tourism framework in the t23
and the third is on our projects as they
fall under the uh shared Prosperity fund
right okay okay councilor Fluker thank
you chairman um
uh no Mr elements I do is that you know
he likes to get in with his bits of
information so I'm certainly going to
top him now and and perhaps trying to
light on your hopes as well because
German it's not often something like
stormzy comes to this district and uh
Records his latest record so I'm sure
I'm sure that uh Mr Ellen's keeping his
uh his powder dry and no doubt we see
him in the background when the when the
video is released but that was at Ocean
Island which we we believe is in the
district anyway yeah because they're
advertising
um as far as though as as far as the
team's meetings next week I think it's a
really good idea I think the notice was
a tad short particularly it says three
over three days and and I know you're
offering alternative dates but I do
wonder whether or not it might be an
idea just to put those up for next week
so members have got an option straight
away I don't know what the take-up is
um on that but I think that would be
quite useful and Timmy going on to the
report page 90.
um you know I've got huge reservations
about you know
sign anything at the market really
because we've tried this many many times
and I know one or two of the market
holders in Chelmsford and their concern
has always been me modern apparently we
don't have a very good footfall in the
High Street on a Saturday morning and
that's tends to be when most Market
Traders do their business and and it is
you know if we go to more than we go in
the afternoon and it's not quite busy in
the morning it's quite quiet so um yeah
I but I think what you're saying is it's
not going to cost us anything to do that
study so that that's fine by me
um and the impact on risk
um I don't quite understand what that
means under implications three
page 91.
it talks about maximizing business rate
growth
but are we talking about
business rate as in the amount of
business that's done all the amount of
tax that you pay that's non-domestic
rates
tax non-demand non-domestic council tax
cool
because you know the whole you know the
great thing about encouraging businesses
to come into this District particularly
The Villages is because they get 100
relief
which
um you know
you know I think that that's you know
that's quite an important thing and it's
a good selling point because I know for
example that parts of Sussex now some
under district councils there are sort
of moving away from that and that for us
that's a really really good selling
point and uh and I think another really
good selling point from the members
perspective would be to perhaps
um audit uh the properties that are
currently on the
district council's websites where we're
we're advertising properties on there
for tourism and it it might be
worthwhile to audit those in relation to
existing Enforcement cases I'll say no
more than that but I think
um perhaps that should be done
um and the impact on the risk
uh whether I'm probably not reading it I
I believe we're trying to say there
um that by having the investment
prospectus and encouraging businesses to
move into the area we mitigate the risk
of having vacant commercial properties
that wouldn't have
um or sorry we we have we hope to have
more businesses come to uh allocated
employment areas and therefore be paying
business rates right okay yeah I think
yeah I think I get it then so Tim I
identifying the last one to speak but if
I might propose that we agree the
recommendations and look forward to
these three briefings next week and the
alternative dates
okay thank you members and we've got
three
recommendations little one that members
note further briefings will be offered
regarding supporting local businesses in
inward investment
tourism in the Vista economy
UK shared Prosperity fund UK SPF and
rural England Prosperity fund our EPF
funded activity little two that members
note the council's Malden District t23
tourism group has commenced a little
three that members endorse the delivery
of the UK SPF year one mold and Market
recovery project and the partnership
with Rural Community Council of Essex to
deliver the repf
do you have a second after that okay
agreed lovely okay
moving on uh agenda rice from eight any
other items of business that the
chairman of the committee decides are
Urgent there are none agenda item nine
exclusion of the public and press to
resolve that under Section 184 of the
Local Government Act 1972 the public we
excluded from the meeting for the
following items of business on the
grounds that they involve the likely
disclosure of exempt information as you
find in paragraph three of part one of
schedule 12a to the ACT and that this
satisfies the public interest test
it's been withdrawn
anyways
and I will I will tell you it's been
resolved but we'll uh I can tell you
that when we go into PNC
age
do we know if we are